liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz zu einem thema das
uns allen unter den nägeln brennt wie
man hier in diesem saal sehen kann und
wie man hier auf dem podium sehen kann
viele experten sind hier unsere gäste
wir begrüßen den gesundheitsminister
jens spahn den präsidenten des robert
koch instituts professor dr
da wieder den direktor des instituts für
virologie der charité berlin professor
doktor christian drosten den
vorstandsvorsitzenden des
bernhard-nocht-instituts für
tropenmedizin professor dr
kann ich die direktorin der institut für
hygiene und umweltmedizin der charité
berlin professor toft petra gastmeier
den leiter des gesundheitsamtes der
stadt frankfurt dr rené gottschalk und
den kbv vize dr stefan hofmeister
herzlich willkommen er spannt sie
starten
vielen dank herr mainz vielen dank für
ihr interesse
seit wochen überschlagen sich die
meldungen über das neue corona virus
immer mehr menschen erkranken auf der
welt in europa und auch hier bei uns in
deutschland und das virus kommt auch
eben bei uns oder ist angekommen in
europa und in deutschland ich habe
letzte woche gesagt wir sind am beginn
einer pandemie offensichtlich weltweit
aber im damit auch eine epidemie hier
bei uns in deutschland
das macht vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern
angst und sorge und das kann ich gut
verstehen denn im gegensatz zu anderen
erkrankungen haben wir alle hat die
bevölkerung die bürgerinnen und bürger
mit diesem jahr mit dieser neuen
atemwegserkrankung aus china keine
erfahrung
wir kennen sie nicht die bürgerinnen und
bürger kennen nur die nachricht dass das
virus immer näher kommt sie kennen die
bilder von menschen in china
in schutzanzügen zu hören und lesen
widersprüchliche warnung von teilweise
jedenfalls zweifelhaften experten
das verunsichert und genau deshalb sind
wir heute hier
wir wollen mit sachinformationen
unsicherheiten abbauen
wir wollen erklären was wir über das
virus stand heute diesen montag
wissen wie man sich schützen kann und
wie wir alles dafür tun eine ausbreitung
so weit als möglich einzudämmen
das wird nicht alle ängste vertreiben
aber das kann helfen die gefahr für den
einzelnen durch das virus realistischer
einzuschätzen und ich will dazu sagen
auch wir haben ja alle über die letzten
wochen dazu gelernt ich weiß noch dass
wir am anfang die vermutung war dass das
virus vor allem im unteren lungenflügel
ist wie bei saks und das für die über
frage wie schnell es übertragbar ist
natürlich deutlich andere folgerungen
hat als wenn wir es jetzt wissen eben
auch viel der viruslast im rachen ist
also über die wochen die letzten konnte
ja auch viel dazu gelernt werden
und das hat dann auch immer wieder eine
anpassung natürlich im umgang damit
erfordert und das wird auch in der
zukunft so sein
ich freue mich dass hier 56 an der kante
experten fünf sind war 66 die volkssagen
ich sage ihnen warum weil wir einen
hochmeister kurzfristig gebeten haben
deswegen sechs dazu kommen von der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung bei
vielen die frage stellen welche tests
werden denn in welcher lage bezahlt das
ist sehe ich ja in vieler regionaler
berichterstattung und die frage was wird
man bezahlt die kann am besten die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung
beantworten lassen 46 dann jetzt hier
miteinander alle experten kommen aus
nachgeordneten behörden des ministeriums
oder haben in den letzten tagen und
wochen seit dem ausbruch des virus an
der 100 stelle mit uns
zusammengearbeitet und uns beraten
der auftritt heute ist teil einer
verstärkten kommunikationsoffensive die
wir als bundesministerium für gesundheit
gestartet haben schon in den letzten
wochen aber jetzt eben noch mal
verstärken
wir haben am wochenende erneut eine
anzeigenkampagne in überregionalen
zeitungen geschaltet heute auch in den
meisten regionalen zeitungen außerdem
informieren wir auf der seite
infektionsschutz de ausführlich und wir
fahren alle hotlines die wir haben hoch
da sich zum glück viele bürgerinnen und
bürger informieren führt das eben
phasenweise dazu dass dann die hotlines
auch sehr stark
sind das heißt es kommt nicht jeder
direkt nach zwei minuten phasenweise
dran
wir haben letzte woche runter mittwoch
donnerstag erlebt das ist ein sehr
großes informationsbedürfnis gab
unsere server kapazitäten sind auch an
grenzen gekommen wir haben sie
kurzfristig jetzt ausgebaut
aber es ist ja erst mal ein gutes
zeichen nämlich eben dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sich informieren
wollen wir spielen auf allen ebenen die
social media kanäle wir produzieren
radiospots die wir den sendern zur
verfügung stellen und das robert koch
institut informiert seit einigen tagen
auch täglich in presse briefings an
dieser stelle sei erwähnt dass auch
andere akteure im gesundheitswesen in
diesem sinne ihrer öffentlichkeitsarbeit
verstärkt haben unter anderem eben die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung um
patienten über das virus zu informieren
etwa wenn sie unter 11 6 11 7 den
ärztlichen bereitschaftsdienst der seit
dem ersten erster diesen jahres auf 24
stunden erreichbar ist und der 11 6 11 7
anrufen das begrüße ich ausdrücklich
denn es ist wichtig dass die
patientinnen und patienten wissen wenn
sie symptome der atemwegserkrankung
entwickeln nachdem sie mit infizierten
kontakt hatten oder aus einem
infektionsgebiet gekommen sind sollten
sie nicht direkt in die praxis gehen
sondern die situation erst einmal mit
ihrem arzt telefonisch klären wenn das
nicht unmittelbar geht im zweifel aber
eben erst mal zu hause bleiben bis eine
solche klärung erfolgen konnte für all
das und auch für die frage was das virus
ist was wir heute da zu wissen wie man
damit umgeht auch in fragen von ideen
und anderes sind jetzt expertinnen und
experten hier wofür ich sehr dankbar bin
und sie sollten jetzt denke ich auch
ihre sicht der dinge dadurch ja vorweg
ich habe schon viele wortmeldungen
gesehen aber erstmal gehen wir hier die
experten durch vielleicht haben sich
dann dir einen oder anderen fragen schon
erledigt wir fangen an mit dem lkw chef
professor wieder der ein wenig zur lage
berichtet bitteschön hat seinen dank
auch früh gekommen
ich möchte kurz noch mal die lage
beschreiben die sehr dynamische ist und
zwar unterscheidet zwischen der lage in
china nach wie vor der weltweiten locken
dann gehe ich besonders auf deutschland
auf um ihnen klar zu machen wie
dynamisch das verläuft
in china haben wir mit stand heute
morgen 80.000 170 fälle und in china
sind insgesamt 2900 15 menschen an
dieser erkrankung verstorben
außerhalb chinas sind inzwischen 64
länder betroffen
in 64 ländern haben wir 8898 fälle
das ist im gegensatz zu gestern eine
zunahme von 1884 fällen das zeigt ihnen
wie schnell sich dieses virus ausbreitet
wir haben insgesamt unter diesen 8898
fällen mindestens 285 schwere
krankheitsverläufe vergessen sind neue
länder dazu gekommen
armenien hier liegt der link zu iran
nach das heißt der patient aus iran hat
das virus nach armenien gebracht
die dominikanische republik hier ist
eine verbindung zur italien hergestellt
worden indonesien
hier denkt man dass es über eines
japanischen kontaktes und touristen und
tschechien wo wir ebenfalls einen link
zu italien herstellen konnten
wenn ich jetzt auf die whu euroregion
gehe bevor ich dann auf deutschland mich
konzentriere
in der bh orion euro da gehört auch dass
gehören viele staaten auch im osten
europas dazu unter anderem die russische
föderation
dort haben wir insgesamt 2200 24 fällen
das heißt innerhalb eines tages über
1800 fälle mehr
das soll ihn einfach nur noch mal die
dynamik beschreibungen klar machen dass
wir wirklich jeden tag eine neue
bewertung durchführen analysen durch in
jeden tag mit neuen daten konfrontiert
sind
in dieser region sind insgesamt 134
menschen an der infektion gestorben und
158 haben schwere krankheitsverläufe das
ist der status heute morgen 8 uhr
wie sieht es in deutschland aus in
deutschland hat sich auch die lüner die
lage sehr dynamisch entwickelt wir haben
mit dem stand heute morgen 8 uhr ein
50 laborbestätigte fälle und die sind in
vielen bundesländern aufgetreten
die meisten fälle finden wir zurzeit in
nordrhein westfalen sind es 86 fälle in
baden württemberg und bei in baden
württemberg sind es 19 und in bayern 26
fälle
insgesamt sind bislang zehn bundesländer
betroffen und 49 landkreise das alter
und das geschlecht der patienten liegen
zwischen 2 und 68 jahre im median sind
die patienten 36 jahre alt und bei 92
fällen ist das geschlecht bekannt sind
es zu 65 prozent männer 60 männer und 32
weibliche patienten bei der mehrheit
dieser fälle aber nicht bei allen aber
das ist ja klar dass man solche
nachfolge untersuchung erst noch macht
kann man einen epidemiologischen link
herstellen was sehr wichtig ist für die
verfolgung
zwei haben einen link nach china 6 nach
iran 18 nach italien und bei 87 handelt
sich um das geschehen in heinsberg in
nordrhein westfalen
das heißt von 140 fällen können wir
bisher einen kontakt nachvollziehen bei
den anderen nicht das kann aber noch
gelingen des status heute ich fasse das
zusammen wir haben ein sehr dynamisches
geschehen globalen und wir bewerten die
lage jeden tag sieben tage die woche neu
letzte woche gab es ein learning pointer
war zum ersten mal mehr fälle außerhalb
chinas berichten worden als innerhalb
chinas und im landkreis heinsberg
herrscht ein starkes ausbruchsgeschehen
in dem aktuell nicht alle
infektionsketten nachvollzogen werden
können das kann sich aber noch ändern
was ganz wichtig ist wir haben für eine
abschließende beurteilung der schwere
der neuen atemwegserkrankungen nicht
genügend daten wir können die schwere
nicht genügend einschätzen wir wissen
aber dass ein teil der fälle schwer
verläuft und wir wissen auch dass
menschen an dieser krankheit sterben
können
wir müssen damit rechnen dass weitere
importe nach deutschland geschehen aber
wir haben natürlich in deutschland
selber
dynamisches geschehen das heißt auch in
deutschland müsse davon ausgehen dass es
weitere übertragung gibt weiter infekt
ketten und lokale infektionsgeschehen
und diese einschätzung kann sich ändern
wir haben die risikoeinschätzung für die
bevölkerung deutschland jetzt auf mäßig
gestellt heute mit dem zeitpunkt heute
und ich kann nur noch mal appellieren an
alle ärzte dass sie entsprechen die
patienten führung so durchführen wie das
für eine solche mögliche krisenfall
gegeben ist und auch noch mal die
verantwortlichen landräte und
bürgermeister
die für solche planungen zuständig sind
sich mit diesen möglichkeiten eines
größeren ausbruchsgeschehen zu befassen
danke vielen dank herr die anderen
experten würde ich bitten sich ein
bisschen kürzer zu fassen erdrosseln
beschäftigt sich jetzt mit der frage wie
gefährlich das virus es bitte schön es
ist fast unmöglich im moment so sagen
wie gefährlich das virus ist
gefährlichkeit ist keine zahl
und das ist eigentlich der grund warum
wir hier erklärungen liefern müssen die
wir zum teil selber nicht haben oder
selber gerade erst dabei sind zu
verstehen und weshalb ein experte der
öffentlichkeit spricht auch immer sagen
muss das kann sich alles innerhalb von
kurzer zeit auch wieder ändern von der
einschätzung her
die fall sterblichkeitsrate ist eine so
eine zahl
dann gibt es kaum ein gutes maß für die
geschwindigkeit der ausbreitung und es
gibt vorstellungen davon was eigentlich
passieren muss bevor eine solche
infektionswelle wieder im endeffekt zum
stillstand kommt und wir dann eine
endemische situation bekommen also ein
normales erkältungsvirus das dann in der
bevölkerung zirkulieren
ich glaube wir müssen diese
unterschiedlichen dinge jetzt im laufe
dieses gesprächs separat besprechen das
ist jetzt zu viel um da in so einer hand
einführungsrede direkt kommentare dran
darauf zu geben
also noch einmal die fall sterblichkeit
dann die einige schätzungen zur
geschwindigkeit der ausbreitung dann was
passieren muss wie lange so eine
pandemie überhaupt dauern würde und dann
vielleicht noch ein paar
implikationen daraus also ich möchte da
jetzt nicht vorgreifen das wäre blöd
okay gut wenn der minister möchte sich
dazu etwas sagen direkt dann mache ich
das mal wir müssen das auch ich will
mich einfach nicht zu sehr verbreiten
hier also gut von der von der fall
sterblichkeit es ist eben so ich schaue
auch in sozialer medien ich bin ja ich
will noch nicht generation y
das sind unsere doktoranden im labor
aber ich schau trotzdem schon in die
sozialen medien
und da sieht man viel drama oder viel
bestrebungen auch zu dramatisieren
und es gibt auch inzwischen sogar firmen
die versuchen geld zu machen mit
informationen also analysten firmen
nennen die sich und was ich da so lese
geht immer in richtung einer möglichst
hohen einschätzung und einer
überbetonung eines risikos und ich sehe
das nicht ehrlich gesagt im moment außer
in ganz grundsätzlichen überlegungen
aber zusätzlich zu diesen
grundsätzlichen überlegungen sehe ich
eigentlich keine richtigen fakten oder
zahlen und deswegen also was da worum es
da eben geht ist zum beispiel so eine so
eine überlegung wie aha die leute die
jetzt in der liste stehen als fälle
die können ja alle in zwei wochen noch
sterben also was ist denn dann also dann
ist ja die fall sterblichkeit viel höher
also solche überlegungen werden da zum
teil unterhalten und ich finde das nicht
gut weil das versteckt wieder einen
anderen aspekt während diese fälle
vielleicht dann tatsächlich schlechter
werden in der zeit kommen ja wieder viel
mehr und überproportional mehr dazu und
das führt dazu dass rein theoretisch
oder rein erwartbar auch die fall
sterblichkeit im laufe der zeit er singt
und geringer wird und im moment sind wir
eher in so einem korridor von 0,3 bis
0,7 prozent fall sterblichkeit und ich
erwarte eigentlich eher dass das sogar
jetzt gerade in nächster zeit noch mal
wieder geringer wird so lange wie das
virus ganz normal frei in der
bevölkerung läuft und noch nicht sehr
große grund infektions lasten in der
bevölkerung sind also wo wir noch fall
ketten haben die von punkten ausgehen
und wie es dann später weitergeht ist
schwer zu sagen
ja zur geschwindigkeit ist es ganz
schwierig also das ist eigentlich das
schwierigste denn daran hängt auch die
der höchste informationswert also ganz
einfach gesagt wenn wir haben viele
milde fälle dieses dieser erkrankung ist
eine milde erkrankung das ist eine
erkältung in erster linie eine erkältung
gegner so die unteren atemwege betrifft
und die ist im prinzip für den einzelnen
gar kein problem also wenn ich eine
erkältung kriege dann werde ich das
nicht nur überleben sondern ich werde im
normalfall sogar relativ wenig davon
merken
die frage ist also vorüber besorgen wir
uns hier eigentlich und wir besorgen wir
sorgen uns um die gesellschaft nicht um
das ego ja also es geht hier nicht um
mich sondern es geht um alle und auch um
das medizinsystem um die kapazitäten die
wir haben die aber auch anderswo sind
zum beispiel in schulen kindergärten und
so weiter also der druck auf die
gesellschaft der kommt durch so eine
erkrankung und die ist sehr von der
geschwindigkeit abhängig
also wenn ich mich heute infiziere ich
als person dann habe ich jetzt
vielleicht ein risiko von 0,5 prozent im
durchschnitt
das habe ich als in meinem alter sowieso
nicht das haben eher die älteren und
wenn ich mich irgendwann infiziere dann
habe ich das wieder aber für die
gesellschaft ist ein großer unterschied
ob alle diese fälle auf einmal kommen
oder ob die sich über lange zeit aus
denen das ist also eigentlich das was
wir hier besprechen müssen und das ist
das was am allerschwersten zu schätzen
ist und gut die die frage die wir die
wir hier zb uns anschauen können ist wie
viele personen werden eigentlich
infiziert bei gruppen die wir beobachten
wenn da zum beispiel ein infizierter ist
und wir schauen alle kontakte an die da
hat also alle menschen mit denen der in
der zeit seiner infektiosität die wir
gut rekonstruieren können
kontakt hatte und dann zählen wir wie
viele haben sich infiziert
das machen wir nicht nur hier bei uns in
deutschland sondern wir schauen auch in
die literatur
dann kommt man auf eine schätzung
vielleicht so von fünf oder auch zehn
prozent das ist die sogenannte sekundäre
trade und diese sekundäre trade mit
dieser zahl liegt unter der sekundären
upgrade von influenza
ich spreche hier nicht von der
saisonalen grippe von sondern von
pandemischen influenza erscheinungen
das heißt da könnte man sich also daraus
ableiten wahrscheinlich wird das so gut
laufen dass das also er sich langsamer
ausdehnt als eine pandemische influenza
das ist so eine hoffnung die in solchen
zahlen drin steckt aber wie gesagt es
kann sein dass ich mich da ganz schätze
und das ist auch nur ein vergleich und
ein influenza-virus ist kein killervirus
da gibt es verschiedene dinge ganz große
unsicherheiten
ich sage ihnen das fast nur er so um mal
prinzipiell überhaupt eine einordnung zu
kriegen aber die kann sich grob ändern
und dann ist eine andere zahl die ist in
der öffentlichkeit ganz stark
aufgenommen worden was mich total
gewundert hat das ist etwas das habe ich
letzte woche meiner talkshow gesagt und
das ist in den englischsprachigen medien
schon lange klar und verbreitet das ist
die frage wie viele werden sich dann
infizieren
und da geht es darum wie viel müssen
sich infizieren damit eine pandemie
stoppt und hier geht es um bevölkerungs
immunität und da können wir und da hatte
ich gesagt das sind so knapp 70 prozent
in seiner talkshow und da haben sich
ganz viele aufgeregt also ich hab da
e-mails geprägt und wurde also fast
schon bedroht ich soll doch aufhören
solche drohszenarien hier aufzubauen
aber das ist etwas ganz natürliches und
auch gar nicht schlimm wenn es sich über
eine zeit aus dem also das entscheidende
ist gar nicht wie viel sich infizieren
sondern das entscheidende ist wie lange
das dauert bis dahin aber nur mal um die
überlegung zu erklären
also wir haben inzwischen projektionen
von einer ausbreitung ziffer dass es die
ddr zimmer ziffer also die
reproduktionsrate der infektion
und die sagt und ich mache das hier
jetzt als rechenbeispiel sagt dass
ungefähr drei personen von einem
infizierten infiziert werden im
durchschnitt
es gibt schätzungen die sagen 22 es gibt
schätzungen die sagen 3,8 wie gesagt wir
sind da am anfang und alle diese zahlen
sind ungenau aber weil man so schön mit
einer kundenzahl rechnen kann rechnen
wir doch mal mit der 3 so und jetzt ist
es
einfach eine ganz leichte frage was muss
denn passieren damit so eine infektion
sich nicht weiter ausbreitet also nicht
einer ist jetzt infiziert drei sind
nächste woche infiziert 19 übernächste
woche infiziert sondern was passiert
wenn das es zum stillstand kommt ganz
einfach wir müssen weniger als einen
folge patienten in jedem übertragungs
gang haben also heute einer nächste
woche einer übernächste woche einer dann
bleibt das konstant einer steckt sich an
einem an
da bleibt alles gleich und wenn es
weniger ist das wird darunter müssen wir
drücken dann hört auf ok so jetzt ganz
anders es sich lohnen würde mit jedem
von ihnen eine extra
bundespressekonferenz zu machen da wir
aber irgendwann auch noch zum ende
kommen müssen soll ich sagen machen wir
jetzt weiter mit herrn professor ta
nicht der sich der inder ist es nicht
ehrlich gesagt ich finde es komisch dass
ich mitten in der erklärung zwei sätze
vor dem ende abgebrochen werde ich würde
das wusste nicht dass es nur noch zwei
sitze sind ja ich versuche gerade etwas
zu erklären bei dem man leider etwas
weiter ausholen muss und ich mache das
jetzt nur noch mal schnell zu ende weil
ich glaube dass alle hier im saal auch
gerne mit denken und das positiv
auffassen werden wenn leicht was etwas
zu verstehen ist und hier ist es einfach
so
wir haben drei personen die sich im
regelfall infizieren wenn wir jetzt aber
immunität kriegen weil sich schon
personen infiziert haben dann kann man
sich ja leicht überlegen wenn sich zwei
von diesen dreien schon infiziert haben
und jetzt immun sind
dann geht es nicht mehr weiter dann ist
schluss mit der pandemie und zwei von
drei sind 67 prozent
daher kommt die zahl dann machen wir
weiter mit herrn professor sonnig und
der frage woran man eine ansteckung
erkennen können einiges ist schon gesagt
worden es gibt kein spezifisches
symptomen indem man diese infektion
erkennt die infektion ist eine infektion
der oberen luftwege erstaunlicherweise
beim minister hat er es schon gesagt
haben ursprünglichen sars virus war es
ja so dass die tieferen luftwegen
betroffen waren hier sind die oberen
luftwege betroffen
ein großer teil der patienten infiziert
muss man sagen hat fast keine symptome
einige haben leichte symptome metalls
kratz noch etwas fieber die stadt schon
nach zwei bis drei tagen wieder
verschwinden und dann gibt es eine
kleine zahl die eine verlängerte
krankheitsphase hat die dann in ganz
wenigen fällen zu einer tiefen infektion
führt und dann eben so analysten
diese sind als die kritischen patienten
die wir im auge behalten müssen und die
wir letztendlich klinisch und versorgung
müssen damit es nicht zu unfällen kommt
die die diagnose kann man nicht nur
beweisen durch einen test wir haben sehr
sehr gute nachweismethoden mit denen wir
dieses dieses virus detektieren können
es gab in der presse einige meldungen
dass wir nicht spezifisch sind mit
unserem test soll anders werden welche
grippe und ihren nachweis nichts nicht
der fall unsere gäste sind 100%
spezifisch für das neue cola virus wir
können also tatsächlich sagen dieser
patient hat ein crooner virus das in
asien in china ursprung genommen hat und
nicht ein gängiges corona virus was
durchaus auch hier bei uns kursiert und
zu infekten der oberen luftwege führen
kann
im moment ist es noch so dass wenn man
solche symptome hat man davon ausgehen
muss dass es sich nicht um ein corona
virus handelt im moment in deutschland
außer man hatte kontakt zu einem
patienten oder war in einem
entsprechenden gebiet gewesen
das wird sie vielleicht ändert in der
nächsten zeit kennen erste fälle von
infektionen bei denen keine kein
zusammenhang mit einer entsprechenden
reise oder mit einem kontakt hergestellt
werden kann und diese fälle werden
wahrscheinlich in der nächsten zeit zu
nehmen so dass wir dann auch fälle
diagnostizieren werden die keine diese
zusammenhänge haben
vielen dank frau professor gastmeier
beschreibt wie man sich schützen kann
bitte schön
ja wenn es um die schutzmaßnahmen geht
dann muss man natürlich sich nochmal
überlegen werden die werden die erreger
übertragen und ich will das noch mal in
den kontext stellen wir unterscheiden
kontakt übertragung tröpfchen übertragen
luft getragen übertragung und masern zum
beispiel um bei windpocken ist es so
dass die übertragung viel dramatischer
ist weil diese erreger in der luft flog
ihren schweren sozusagen und selbst wenn
der patient den raum verlassen hat immer
noch virus partikel in der luft sind die
eingeatmet werden können eine infektion
hervorrufen können bei masern und
windpocken kriegt uns das aber nicht so
furchtbar auf weil die meisten von uns
diese infektion entweder durch gemacht
haben oder durch die info gut geschützt
sind
beim corona virus ist es so dass wir
eine tröpfchen information infektion
haben und sie haben ja alle gehört
dementsprechend ist es also wichtig zum
beispiel in die ellenbeuge zu nah zu
lesen oder eben die hände gut zu waschen
gründlich zu waschen wenn man kontakt zu
entsprechenden patienten hatte der
entscheidende punkt ist aber denke ich
dass man wirklich abstand hält zu den
patienten die betroffen sind aber
natürlich auch in so einer phase
vielleicht überhaupt mehr den abstand zu
den mitbürgern einschränkt in dem sinne
den herd osten angesprochen hat dass man
also die ausbreitung des virus in der
bevölkerung verlangsamt und reduziert
und mir geht es immer wieder selber so
dass jemand auf einen zukommt und mein
unwillkürlich zum beispiel die hand
ausstreckt das sollte man in dieser
phase eben einfach mal nicht machen und
ich denke wir brauchen da
implementierungs hilfen auch zum
beispiel wenn ihm jemand auf ihn zukommt
und möchte an die hand geben dass man
dann sagt kroner stoppt das ist nicht so
furchtbar elegant diese geste vielleicht
haben sie selber gute ideen für für eine
schöne geste die man da entwickeln
könnte und die man eben zeigen könnte
und dann wissen sofort alle dieser
mensch ist nicht unfreundlich sondern
der wir in diesen zeiten einfach nur
keine
händeschütteln oder eben auch nicht
seine mitbürger drücken ich denke also
dieser punkt abstand halten ist der
wichtigste punkt an dem wir uns gewöhnen
sollten in diesen zeiten so dann kommen
wir zu der frage wie statische stellen
reagieren und gehen nach frankfurt zu
herrn gottschalk bitteschön die erste
pandemie in diesem jahrtausend war ein
corona virus sarahs genannt christian
drosten war damals ja auch mit beteiligt
jetzt haben wir wieder ein corona virus
saß zwei sozusagen
die gute nachricht dabei ist aber dass
es wahrscheinlich nicht so gefährlich
ist wie das damalige saß virus insgesamt
hat ja hätten auch schon ausgeführt dass
die sterblichkeit er in der
größenordnung einer influenza also einer
grippewelle liegt die gute nachricht ist
auch dass im prinzip alle pandemien mit
den maßnahmen des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes zum stehen gebracht
werden können
auch wenn keine therapie jetzt kann
spezifische therapie oder noch keine
impfung verfügbar ist wir müssen nur es
schaffen dass wir diese berühmte r 0
zahl auf 1 oder unter 1 bringen und das
wird auch gelingen da bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich verglichen zu masern mit
er 08 10 bis 20 also ein patient steckt
bis zu 20 anfragen wird uns das auch
ganz sicher gelingen so abschließend
noch die einschätzung wann soll man kann
getestet werden bitte schön
ja das ist relativ klar entlang der
richtlinien des rk ii soll getestet
werden und insbesondere um der
überbelastung des systems zu vermeiden
sollten natürlich die die leicht
erkältet sind und keinen kontakt hatten
nicht zwingend jetzt irgendwo in lauffen
zum testen
die tests werden selbstverständlich
bezahlt sowie auch alle anderen
leistungen so dass das überhaupt kein
problem darstellt und der entscheidende
satz für uns als kassenarzt
bundesvereinigung für die
vertragsärztinnen und ärzte ist dass der
regelbetrieb funktionieren muss
aufrechterhalten was wir haben ja neben
der korona pandemie vor allem auch noch
viele andere kranke menschen zu
versorgen in den praxen und das ist
eigentlich die hauptaufgabe ist dass wir
im engen schulterschluss mit den anderen
institutionen hier versuchen
kommunikativ zu helfen
die gleichen botschaften aus zu bringen
um zu beruhigen um zu aufzuklären und
sicherzustellen dass die menschen
versorgt werden und die tests sind da es
kann getestet werden das neben
bundesland ein bisschen anders aber es
ist überhaupt kein problem
im ambulanten system auch an diese tests
zu kommen
dann kommen wir zu fragen neun habe ich
schon herr grimm hatte sich als erster
gemeldet bitteschön also zum ersten gibt
es eigentlich für jedes unternehmen auch
einen pandemieplan
wir haben ja den influenza pandemieplan
des bundes der länder nach der
schweinegrippe vor zehn jahren
entwickelt überarbeitet seit 2012 wir
nicht richtig im kopf
15-16 dann noch mal überarbeitet aber
damals eben zum ersten mal in dem umfang
auch sehr ausführlich es gibt halt nicht
nur ein pandemie planung des bundes und
der länder sondern jedes krankenhaus
jede pflegeeinrichtung der
rettungsdienst und eben auch unternehmen
sollten über eine entsprechende
pandemieplanung verfügen empfehlungen
und hinweise dazu gibt es im bundes
pandemieplan der auch öffentlich
verfügbar ist beim robert-koch-institut
und es ist ihnen keine influenza
pandemie ist ein grippevirus aber wir
haben dort schon gehört zumindest auch
meinen der erkrankungsform
atemwegserkrankung ist manche seien
maßnahmen jedenfalls vergleichbar
und wir sind auch gerade dabei den
pandemieplan auf corona virus
entsprechend dem rahmen anzupassen das
heißt das unternehmen muss ich natürlich
einfach mit der frage beschäftigen das
kann eigentlich meinen dass das
handwerksunternehmen das nur lokal tätig
war ist natürlich anders zu bewerten als
der internationale konzern wo es einen
regen austausch untereinander
gibt wo möglicherweise kolleginnen und
kollegen gerade aus china oder
norditalien zurückgekehrt sind und
deswegen kann man aus meiner sicht
jedenfalls weiß nicht ob er gottschalk
vielleicht auch noch mal mit der
erfahrung des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes da ergänzen kann aus
meiner sicht keine pauschale aussage
treffen sondern es ist eben für jedes
unternehmen sozusagen zu bewerten wer
hatte mit bmw kontakt und auch wie sind
ansteckungsgefahren dann im unternehmen
wie sitzt man die frage großraumbüros
einzelbüro systemen kann mannheim arbeit
machen
das gleiche gilt übrigens auch für
großveranstaltungen in diesen in diesen
tagen wo wir ja auch seitens des bundes
einige parameter formuliert haben im
krisenstab aber die entscheidung da kann
auch herr gottschalk im zweifel was zu
sagen ob eine großveranstaltung
stattfindet nicht ich lese jetzt immer
die forderung der bundesminister müsste
also groß veranstaltung absagen
das infektionsschutzgesetz sieht vor
dass das eben die behörden vor ort
entscheiden
wir definieren parameter und die frage
ob eine großveranstaltung ausschließlich
publikum aus deutschland hat oder auch
viel publikum international wie bei der
ezb ist gewesen wäre
macht für eine solche beurteilung ein
unterschied
und ich würde auch ein kreisligaspiel in
heinsberg im moment anders bewerten als
ein kreisligaspiel in schleswig holstein
also ich muss auch das regionale
ausbruchsgeschehen dabei berücksichtigt
er ist genau wie minister sparen sagt
man muss jedes mal im prinzip für jede
veranstaltung für jeden betrieb für jede
firma eine eigene risikobewertung machen
das ist zwar ein bisschen umständlich
aber das lohnt sich wenn man das macht
und da ist es in der tat so dass man
nicht ganze firmen stilllegen muss
sondern wenn wirklich gefahr besteht
dass ein mitarbeiter aus dem ausland
oder woher auch immer eine entsprechende
infektion mitgebracht hat es gilt ja
nicht nur jetzt wird es neue corona
virus dann muss man eben da gezielt und
da macht es auch wirklich sind eine
kontaktperson suche machen um
gegebenenfalls da diesen bereich zu
klären aber eine ganze firma zu
schließen
das halte ich doch für ein bisschen
zogen nächste frage von ein heller bitte
wer mag ich kann das gerne beantworten
herr droste kann ich dann gerne ergänzen
weil er die münchner fälle mit den
kliniken zusammen intensiver bearbeitet
prinzipiell ja zurzeit ist es so dass
die fälle runtergehen das sind
glaubwürdige zahlen das kann ich so
sagen weil ein mitarbeiter von uns im
rahmen der whu eine reaktion in der
letzten woche vor ort gewesen ist und
sehr sehr viele detaillierte einblicke
erhalten hat es gibt dazu uns auch einen
bericht in jeder lesen kann der ist am
freitag glaublich oder samstag online
gestellt worden
das heißt aber natürlich nicht dass das
zwingend so sein muss in der zukunft
auch denn natürlich kann auch china die
ganz drastischen quarantänemaßnahmen in
ihren städten auch nicht ewig weiter
fahren es kann also auch in china wieder
dazu kommen dass neue fälle entstehen
das kann man nicht ausschließen das muss
nicht sein aber das kann man nicht
ausschließen
sie sagen die frage nach infektion
mehrfach infektionen
das ist eine frage die wir aus meiner
sicht noch nicht beantworten können
aktuell
ich denke es sind zwei plausible gründe
warum diese frau das virus noch
ausgeschieden hat das erste ist wir
haben in münchen einen patienten der uns
putzmunter und gesund ist
er scheitert aber das virus einfach sehr
sehr lange aus noch und das ist auch gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich ist aber das hat
für die epidemiologische
weiterverbreitung wahrscheinlich gar
keine besondere rolle das ist ein
einzelfall
das ist also eine möglichkeit die zweite
möglichkeit ist die dass die dame in
japan die berichtet wurde einfach das
virus zwischendurch nachweismethoden
quasi vielleicht falsch negatives
angezeigt haben uns ist die ganze
ausgeschieden ab die immunität zu der
können wir noch nicht sehr viel sagen
ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass wir
das ganze geschehen erst überhaupt seit
wenigen wochen wissen das heißt also die
immunität die zeigt sich hier erst im
laufe der zeit
man weiß dass diese patienten
neutralisierende antikörper haben das
heißt also die haben antikörper mit
denen das virus in einem zellkultur test
neutralisiert also quasi aufgehalten
werden kann zerstört werden kann
die vermehrung gehindert werden kann wie
lange die immunität ist das werden wir
hinterher beantworten können zurzeit
wissen es nicht ich weiß nicht christian
ob du noch das ergänzen kannst ja also
man kann vielleicht noch dazu sagen
jetzt zu dieser frage der mehrfach
infektionen dass diese erkrankung gerade
dazu verleitet auch missverständnisse zu
haben jetzt auch zwischen ärzten und
patienten zb also nur mal ganz kurz
darüber nachgedacht jemand kommt ins
krankenhaus ist eigentlich komplett
gesund und wird da nur isoliert
irgendwann wird er dann entlassen
vielleicht weil auch andere patienten da
sind die wirklichen bett brauchen also
wir reden jetzt über fälle aus china die
da berichtet worden sind geht nach hause
und dann ist es bei dieser erkrankung so
dass einige wenige patienten die die
schwer werden schwere verläufe kriegen
die kriegen diese verläufe erst in der
zweiten woche beim geht der patient also
wieder erkranken ins krankenhaus
vielleicht auch in ein anderes
krankenhaus und sagt dort ich war doch
letzte woche schon im krankenhaus jetzt
bin ich wieder im krankenhaus da war es
positiv jetzt ist es positiv also könnte
man das verwechselt und ich habe mir es
gibt inzwischen eine wissenschaftliche
aufarbeitung dieser fälle die mich nicht
überzeugt
da sind noch zu viele informationslücken
drin um jetzt so sagen man kann sich
unmittelbar in kurzer zeit folge
mehrfach mit diesem virus infizieren
das glaube ich jetzt erstmal so nicht
entschuldbar ist der nächste
sie sitzen da habe ich sie bitte also
zum ersten sehen wir dieses
infektionsgeschehen mittlerweile auch
nicht mehr nur wie am anfang in 23
ländern europas in einzelfällen sondern
in fast jedem
ich weiß gar nicht wie viel genau
betroffen sind aber nach und nachher in
jedem europäischen land und das zeigt
übrigens ja auch wie eng unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger jeden tag
miteinander verwoben sind
ob touristisch ob geschäftlich oder
privat
allein die situation in norditalien hat
eben dazu geführt dass über die zeit in
vielen anderen ländern dadurch folge
infektionen aufgetreten sind
wir haben uns ja in rom letzte woche das
geht ja alles so schnell es war erst
letzte woche dienstag in rom getroffen
mit den kollegen aus der nachbarregion
nord italiens und auch über diese frage
beraten und die frage ist ja was ist
verhältnismäßig und angemessen das ist
ja auch in relation zu nehmen was wir
gerade über das virus gehört haben über
seinen verlauf und über die erkrankungs
folge dieses hat und der schweizer
kollege hat zum beispiel sehr
eindrücklich beschrieben dass in der
italienischen schweiz das
gesundheitswesen massiv davon abhängt
dass jeden morgen berufspendler ärzte
und pflegekräfte über die grenze kommen
das heißt eine maßnahme zu sagen ich
will da die infektion nicht im land
haben deswegen schließlich die grenzen
hätte massive folgen gehabt für die
medizinische versorgung in der
italienischen schweiz weil viele gar
nicht mehr
den krankenhäusern hätten arbeiten gehen
können und deswegen muss man bei jeder
maßnahme die man trifft selbst wenn sie
eine ganze stadt ich lese immer man
müsste mehr unter quarantäne stellen
in dem moment wo sich eine stadt unter
quarantäne stellen hat das für die
patienten den schlaganfall haben den
herzinfarkt haben die medikamente
brauchen jeden tag ja auch wieder folgen
und ich finde wir müssen halt immer in
jeder situation abwägen welche folge hat
die maßnahme auch für die medizinische
versorgung geht mir gar nicht um
ökonomie und wirtschaft zuerst sondern
einfach mal für die versorgungslage der
bevölkerung und welche maßnahme welche
folgen hätte ist für die eindämmung der
erkrankung und ich bin sehr froh darüber
dass wir eben gemeinsam gesagt haben
dass und das sehe ich weiterhin eine
woche später so dass das schließen von
grenzen oder das beschränken der
reisefreiheit in europa keine
angemessene und verhältnismäßige
entscheidung wäre im übrigen will ich
auch mal darauf hinweisen dass das erste
und einzige land das alle direktflüge
mit china beendet hat frühzeitig beendet
hat das land ist das als erstes sehr
stark betroffen war weil ich ja
verschiedentlich auch die forderung lese
und müsse direkt flüge einstellen da
vielleicht auch dazu folgenabschätzung
darauf hinweisen dass das einstellen von
direktflügen aus einem land dazu führt
dass die dort befindlichen deutschen
evakuiert werden müssten
das muss man ja mal hat es zu ende
denken wenn wir sagen würden keine
direktflüge mehr aus china während
30.000 deutsche ist die schätzung in
china die er dann sagen würden wir
müssen hier raus
also ich würde nur darauf hinweisen dass
jede entscheidung ich muss man abwägen
und in jeder abwägung nicht natürlich
immer dann sozusagen die
unterschiedlichen argumente und die
unterschiedlichen positionen ich will
auch noch eines sagen ich muss jetzt mal
einfach auf den punkt zu bringen so in
manchen diskussion mit der lese werden
karneval absagen müssen vor karneval war
die situation in deutschland die das es
16 infizierte gab infektionsketten waren
abschließend bekannt davon wenn es
richtig im kopf noch alle 14 schon
wieder gesund zu hause hätten wir zu dem
zeitpunkt gesagt alles wird abgesagt
weiß ich nicht ob das
die richtige reaktion auf die lage
gewesen wäre
und das ist das was ich immer
beschrieben habe mit der dynamischen
lage in der wir sind
wir lernen mehr das ist jetzt denn die
wissenschaftliche teil über das virus
vor sechs wochen vor acht wochen wussten
wir nicht das was wir ihnen gerade hier
vortragen konnten die kolleginnen und
kollegen und wir haben halt eine
dynamische lage auch in der zahl des
oder infektionsgeschehen im land und das
ist das was ich immer gesagt habe das
ist das dass wir das im blick haben
müssen dass ich immer nur eine
positionierung eine standpunkt eine
wissensvermittlung machen kann wie alle
anderen hier vorne auch zum zeitpunkt
der dann wenn wir sagen und schon zwei
tage später kann die situation ebenso
sein dass wir wieder neu reagieren
müssen oder dinge anders einschätzen
müssen aber die kurze antwort auf ihre
frage wären ein
die nächste frage von ihnen herr kollege
bitte
[Musik]
das herausfordernde für uns alle ist ja
dass wir eben nicht abschließend wissen
so etwas neues dieses virus und als es
erstmalig in china im begann zum
jahreswechsel wann genau in china wissen
wir ja nicht ganz genau
im laufe des dezembers dann wusste ja
auch keiner was was ist das jetzt für
ein virus
was hat es in der folge für eine
symptomatik wir sind all die parameter
die hier gerade schon beschrieben worden
sind und soweit ich das richtig sehe die
professoren mal an wissen wir es immer
noch nicht abschließend sondern wir
lernen jeden tag wir wissen schon
deutlich mehr als vor sechs wochen über
die frage wie es einzuschätzen ist und
aus dieser unsicherheit heraus haben wir
alle eben den das vorsichtsprinzip
vorangestellt also im zweifel eben zum
beispiel die zentrale unterbringung der
wo hahn rückkehrer
das ist die erste maßnahme dieser
größenordnung die es in der
bundesrepublikanischen geschichte
gegeben hat über 120 menschen die aus
einem anderen land zurückkehren zentral
unter quarantäne zu stellen hat es
vorher noch nie gegeben und es gab leute
die das kritisiert haben ist das
verhältnismäßig und wir haben gesagt in
einer zeit wo wir noch nicht viel wissen
über dieses virus ist das aus unserer
sicht verhältnismäßig weil es eben den
schutz der betroffenen gilt der
rückkehrer aber auch dem schutz der
bevölkerung insgesamt sind aus dieser
unsicherheit heraus und den bildern ich
habe das vorher beschrieben die man
sieht natürlich mit schutzanzügen weil
eben alle sehr vorsichtig da rangehen
entstehen natürlich dann unsicherheiten
insgesamt das ist denke ich eben auch
dann unsere verantwortung übrigens unser
aller verantwortung hier im raum und das
wir machen wir diese pressekonferenz
auch die dinge so einzuordnen dass man
eben jenseits der überschriften damit
oder auch durch überschritten manchmal
vielleicht damit entsprechend umgehen
kann
was die lebensmittel situation angeht so
auch da dass es vereinzelt wenn alle
gleichzeitig in einem stadtteil
konserven kaufen gehen dann für ein oder
zwei tage
das regal etwas leerer ist und dann die
fotos gepostet werden und dann sagen sie
cook in deutschland ist kein essen mehr
da ja so dass das aber das regal zwei
tage später wieder voll ist und dass wir
dass wir in der entwicklung vielleicht
mal weg müssen von ich mach ein foto und
stehst du darauf auf alles und auf die
zukunft das ist glaube ich eine
verantwortung die wir gemeinsam haben an
der stelle und ich sage noch mal eben
das sehr sehr ernst hat professor
drosten hat darauf hingewiesen dass das
eine ist was ist die situation für den
einzelnen und das andere ist die frage
was macht das mit der gesellschaft und
zwar als macht das mit der gesellschaft
in der frage gesundheitssystem
es wird unser gesundheitssystem unter
stress setzen das tut es in heinsberg
schon zum beispiel und die frage wie
sehr ist das unter stress jetzt wird
sich danach bemessen wie schnell wie er
professor thorsten ist mir schon immer
passiert das alles in vier wochen oder
in zwei jahren
und da bin ich bei den
großveranstaltungen die frage ob es in
vier wochen oder in zwei jahren
sozusagen sich entwickelt und ob wir das
damit umgehen können hat was damit zu
tun wie schnell sich jetzt menschen
infizieren können und das auf
großveranstaltungen das risiko je
nachdem wir die angelegt ist
ich habe vor ein paar parameter
beschrieben im größer ist als nicht das
ist glaube ich auf dem kundig und
deswegen an bestimmten stellen in
deutschland wird alltag ein stück
eingeschränkt sein müssen siehe
heinsberg schulschließungen kindergarten
schließung sehe die empfehlung der baden
württembergischen landesregierung zu
sagen dass diejenigen die aus
norditalien aus dem urlaub zurückkehren
da ist ja gerade auch großer
rückreiseverkehr die kinder im zweifel
zwei wochen nicht in die schule oder im
kindergarten um eben infektionsketten
möglichst zu reduzieren und zu
unterbrechen
das ist genau das ziel ist zu
verlangsamen ist einzudämmen und ist vor
allem eben damit auch besser händel war
für den einzelnen aber auch für die
gesamtgesellschaft zu machen das ist aus
meiner sicht die große überschrift und
gleichzeitig und dafür soll diese
pressekonferenz ja aber dieses
pressegespräch diese
dieses gemeinsame information hier bei
ihnen in der bundespressekonferenz sein
eben auch immer wieder einordnen was mit
dem virus ist was ist mit uns macht habe
ich auch ein starkes gefühl nämlich dass
wir die nachfolgende
regierungs-pressekonferenz später
beginnen lassen als nächstes ist der hof
mantra britische welches micro das hier
ich würde sagen öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst kann am besten aus der
täglichen praxis dr gottschalk also ich
hatte vorhin schon gesagt es gab ja
schon viele pandemien die wir diese erde
gezogen und immer ist im prinzip
zumindest in deutschland des
gesundheitsamt eben als untere
ausführende behörde für den solchen
schutz zuständig das ist nichts neues in
den fraktions schutzgesetz in der auch
weitreichende möglichkeiten gegeben dass
man das schaffen kann
ihre frage bezieht sich aber darauf dass
eben der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
in der tat nicht optimal ausgestattet
ist aber in solchen fällen ist es so
dass das ganze amt wenn fall ein
kleineres amtes im sinne des
infektionsschutz umfunktioniert wird das
ist auch etwas was dann zu
einschränkungen führen kann die minister
sparen angesprochen hat da dort hat man
den schuleingangsuntersuchungen für die
kinder etwas länger weil eben die
mitarbeiter in dem bereich
infektionsschutz mitarbeiten müssen aber
ich bin da eigentlich guter dinge dass
da auch die deutschen gesundheitsämter
knapp 400 an der zahl gut aufgestellt
sind und wenn man mal sieht das
mittlerweile schon von den weltweiten
fallzahlen die hälfte wieder sich erholt
hat dann glaube ich wirklich dass wir
das auch hinkriegen werden gefällt
einfach mal zur information zu einer
gesundheitsamt tag habe ich 250
mitarbeiter und 50 ärzte in frankfurt
also ich finde man muss vielleicht auch
mal beschreiben was auch daher sind
strukturen bei uns ist halt so dass wir
ein sehr großes amt sind wir haben
natürlich auch den flughafen deswegen
sind wir gerade was den infektionsschutz
angeht sehr gut aufgestellt und bei uns
lässt sich das relativ problemlos noch
regeln und ich denke auch die meisten
großstadt gesundheitsämter sind ähnlich
gut aufgestellt und bei kleineren ämtern
muss man sich halt gegenseitig
wie gesagt insbesondere die die
umstellung des amtes auf den
infektionsschutz die bringt sehr viel
zur frage der veranstaltung übrigens die
kriterien sind da keine geheimen oder
prinzipien dinge sondern auf den seiten
des robert koch institutes auch abrufbar
als ergebnis eben des krisenstabes vom
freitag und die parameter sind zum
beispiel die frage ich habe es ja vorhin
schon angedeutet der teilnehmerkreis
sind teilnehmer aus risikogebieten dabei
china südkorea japan iran norditalien
oder sind keine dabei macht für die
bewertung schon ein unterschied es ist
ein internationales europäisches
publikum oder möglicherweise nur ein
regionales macht für die beurteilung
schon ein unterschied sind die
teilnehmer feuer bekannt oder es ist
eine öffentliche publikumsveranstaltung
wo man gar nicht weiß wer kommt macht
für die beurteilung ein unterschied
die frage wie ist überhaupt die
räumlichkeit wie ist die belüftung
es ist eine klimaanlage die eher ein
infektionsgeschehen befördert oder ist
es eher eine belüftung die eine
infektionsgeschehen reduziert ist es
drinnen oder draußen
also es gibt eine ganze reihe von
parametern wie kooperativ ist der
veranstalter sowie ist auch ein
parameter ist da jemand der bereit ist
tatsächlich an auflagen mitzuarbeiten
ermöglichen oder nicht
das sind eben parameter die dabei eine
rolle spielen und spielen können
übrigens gibt es zwischen stattfinden
lassen und absagen ja auch noch
zwischentöne einschränken
teilnehmerkreis reduzieren oder auch
bestimmte eben auflagen zu machen was
infektionen angeht ich weiß nicht mal ob
sie für die frage wie
großveranstaltungen oder veranstalter
umgehen könnten noch aus dem hygiene
aspekt hinweise haben so das sind die
parameter und dann muss eben im
einzelnen und ich sage noch einmal nach
dem infektionsschutzgesetz kann es auch
nur die behörde vor ort die behörde vor
ort entscheiden ob die veranstaltung
stattfindet oder nicht
und das gilt auch für veranstaltungen
vier acht oder zwölf wochen
ich denke es ist schwer heute am anfang
märz zu sagen wie die situation in acht
oder zwölf wochen sein wird in der
letzten pressekonferenz wurde ja hier
gefragt schon nach der em und nach der
frage kann eigentlich die die olympiade
stattfinden das sind alles dinge die man
denke ich nicht jetzt schon entscheiden
kann sondern zeit näher zu den
veranstaltungen dann tatsächlich auch
weil man dann weiß wie es dann
infektionsgeschehen ausschaut
die entschädigungsfrage vielleicht noch
ihr habt immer dann vielleicht noch
ergänzen das sozusagen die fälschung
situation noch mal was ganz wichtig ist
sie hatten das ja auch schon angedeutet
also wenn sie ein rockkonzert haben
würde leute sehr eng miteinander kontakt
haben es das was anderes als wenn die
leute zum beispiel in einem parteitag
noch ein bisschen mehr distanziert
voneinander sich im raum finden ist an
der partei wahrscheinlich aber zu der
frage regress und entschädigung
man sieht ja was zu sagen wir ungern
weil meistens sind wir nämlich dann in
der pflicht also es ist in der tat so
wenn aufgrund von massnahmen der
desinfektions schutzes der öffentlichen
gesundheitsbehörden eine veranstaltung
abgesagt werden muss dann muss natürlich
auch die öffentliche hand dafür gerade
stehen wir ja noch mal ganz generell ein
paar worte das ist ein ganz klares
strategisches überlegtes vorgehen was
wir seit mehreren wochen in deutschland
tun
wir haben bestimmte pläne dieser
pandemie plan sagte minister spanien
steht im netz kennt jeder wenn er möchte
kann er rein schauen wir haben ganz
klare kriterien anhand der wir das habe
ich extra deshalb eben bitte und jeden
tag die situation einschätzen
dann gibt es plötzlich ein neues
risikogebiet damit gibt es menschen die
aus dem risiko gebiet kommen werden dann
anders klassifiziert als menschen aus
wie auch kein risikogebiet kommen dann
gibt es plötzlich personen die auf einer
veranstaltung waren
vielleicht viele sich angesteckt haben
dann werden diese personen anders
behandelt als wenn sie aus dem anderen
gebiet kommen wir passen das regelmäßig
an
wir evaluieren oder wir sprechen ständig
über die kriterien
wir geben die informationen auf der
website raus das heißt dass ein
strategischer plan natürlich dann auf
der ebene und darum habe ich noch mal
eben ganz klar darauf hingewiesen die
bürgermeister und die landräte sind ja
die das lässt sich entscheiden wie auf
dieser ebene dann dazu führen dass die
entscheider kriterien an der hand haben
nach denen sie nach bestem wissen und
gewissen eine veranstaltung absagen oder
eben nicht
das ist ein maßnahmenkatalog der wohl
überlegt ist ein strategisch immer
weiter detailliert aufgedröselt wird bis
auf die untere ebene und das werden wir
die ganze zeit tun solange diese
epidemie in deutschland sein wird werden
wir ein klares strategisches vorgehen
wie wir dafür sorge tragen dass sich das
virus möglich langsam davon sprechen sie
seit wochen entschleunigen möglichst
langsam in unserer population verbreitet
damit wir das handeln können das werden
wir jeden tag so weitermachen
das mikro ein bisschen an die frage was
das an wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen hat
für unterschiedliche branchen aber auch
für möglicherweise betroffene
unternehmen ist ja eine wo der finanz-
und wirtschaftsminister schon
angekündigt haben dass sie sich damit
beschäftigen
ich denke am ende wird es auch darum
gehen dass zielgerichtet zu machen und
vor allem auch immer zuschauen wodurch
entstehen wirtschaftliche probleme wenn
ein unternehmen aus guter überlegung
entscheidet ganz oder in teilen zu sagen
wir machen jetzt zwei wochen weil viel
kontakt da war mal alle kommen zur ruhe
dann hat das natürlich wirtschaftliche
folgen dem moment nicht abgefedert sind
das ist die frage
adressiert man dass die frage dass aus
china zulieferung sich möglicherweise
die container sind der vier wochen
unterwegs manche mögen noch
dinge auf lager haben aber irgendwann
nach einer zeit wird es sicher bemerkbar
machen übrigens ja nicht nur in der
automobil- und maschinenbauindustrie
sondern auch in teilen der der
gesundheitswirtschaft das zulieferungen
aus china nicht kommt ob man das
adressiert sind themen die jetzt
sicherlich auch innerhalb der
bundesregierung besprochen werden und
mein eindruck ist dass wir da auch mit
den kollegen oder ist die kollegen den
ressorts wir sind ja auch im ständigen
austausch sich dazu auch gedanken machen
wir jetzt mit der nächsten frage
[Musik]
der erste fall kann nicht ganz wirklich
ganz einfach beantworten
die zahlen gibt es jeden tag auf der
website des robert-koch-instituts jeden
tag stehen sie dort und werden berichtet
und dann komme ich nochmal auf den
aspekt den herr droste richtiger weise
angesprochen hat und denen auch ich
angesprochen habe
das sind natürlich die wahren zahlen die
wir haben aber wir wissen natürlich dass
es nicht alle fälle widerspiegelt die
sind wirklichkeit gibt das ist ja klar
die wahre zahl wie viele menschen
infiziert sind
die wird natürlich größer sein ja die
werden es werden niemals alle fälle die
irgendwann mal infiziert sind gerade
weil die krankheit in den meisten fällen
ja wirklich sehr sehr milde verläuft
wird die wahre zahl natürlich am ende
mal berechenbar sein und und extra
polier bar sein aber das heißt dass
dadurch eigentlich klar ist dass
insgesamt der anteil der schwer
verlaufenden fälle kleiner ist weil wir
die wahre zahl der mild verlaufende
wahrscheinlich niemals erfahren werden
aber die zahlen die dort stehen sind die
zahlen die wir liefern können wir
spekulieren nicht gerne
es werden auch viele modellierungen
viele leute viele wissenschaftler
modellieren mit zahlen und ich bitte sie
alle die diese zahlen lesen da gibt es
die reihe von publikationen wenn sie die
bitte richtig lesen denn alle diese
modellierer sagen da sind eine riesige
zahl von unsicherheiten drin genau wie
ich drosten das beschreibt das sind
riesige schwankungen möglichkeiten lasst
sie uns dafür sorge tragen dass wir so
lange wie möglich eindämmen in
deutschland dass wir die geschwindigkeit
verlangsamen und dass sich die
krankenhäuser und alle darauf
vorbereiten dass patienten kommen und
dann werden wir die wahren zahlen wissen
aber wir müssen uns darauf vorbereiten
damit wie dies geschehen in den griff
kriegen ganz einfach auch für den
regelbetrieb kann man das klar
bestätigen es gibt sowohl für alle
durchgeführten tests klare nachweise und
für jedes positive testergebnis auch so
dass es auch im ambulanten
betrieb die zahlen vorliegen und
gemeldet werden da kann es gar kein
zweifel geben wenngleich natürlich gilt
dass wir nicht jeden menschen testen
also die dunkelziffer sozusagen die ist
natürlich davon unbenommen gerufen was
da können sie vielleicht noch mal was
sagen auch zu den infos die an die ärzte
ja also da sind wir natürlich auch
herausgefordert denn auch bei den ärzten
und den mitarbeitenden praxen macht das
verunsicherung keine frage auch diese
nicht gefeit von verschiedenen
informationen beeinflusst zu werden
deswegen versuchen wir die sehr
einheitlich abzustimmen sind alle praxen
informiert das sind über die
kassenärztliche vereinigung die kbv auf
allen medien informationen abgeglichen
mit dem lka weitergeleitet worden so
dass die praxen vorbereitet sein sollten
und können auf die felle und auf die
patienten patienten die dort anlanden
und wir versuchen auch dort zu
deeskalieren und darauf hinzuweisen dass
der regelbetrieb im vordergrund steht
und die gott sei dank ja meistens plante
verlaufenden infekt fälle außer in den
index fällen die wir zwingen testen
müssen und sollen eben lieber zu hause
bleiben und sich ein paar tage erholen
von ihrer erkältung anstatt in die
praxen zu laufen vielleicht die praxis
zu infizieren und die praxis dann vom
netz genommen wird
insofern sind wir da an einer ganz
streng und klaren informationen
interessiert und kommunizieren die auch
seit jetzt einer woche an die praxen zu
der frage vielleicht auch noch mal zu
der frage was für den hausgebrauch frau
professor gastmeier eigentlich sinn
mache doch das ist vielleicht noch mal
wichtig zur einordnung für den einzelnen
was jetzt aber erstmal die
versorgungslage angeht
desinfektionsmitteln preise die sie
angesprochen haben sind wir auch in den
gesprächen mit der apothekerschaft
desinfektionsmittel ist etwas was
apotheker ja auch durchaus selbst
herstellen können
ob und wie man das
regulatorisch noch vereinfachen sollte
oder nicht um das möglich zu machen
ansonsten nehme ich auch war das
natürlich in der verknappung die auf der
welt einfach da ist weil überall auf der
welt alle länder alle krankenhäuser alle
praxen aber auch privatpersonen gerade
bestimmte produkte kaufen
desinfektionsmittel bestimmte
schutzkleidung masken und anderes mehr
eben dann die preise leider teilweise
sind wie sie wie sie sind und das beste
was wir machen können ist dafür zu
sorgen dass eben diese diese verknappung
bei desinfektionsmitteln ist das eine
das andere ist bei den schutzmasken dass
wir das besser steuern und auch
zielgerichteter steuern ist braucht
nicht jeder eine maske zu hause das kann
vielleicht frau professor gast man ja
noch mal auch einfach weil wenn ich das
sache ist wenn man eine andere wirkung
wenn die hygieniker wenn das sagt
vielleicht an der stelle
und gleichzeitig müssen wir in den
praxen sicherstellen auch da sind wir in
gesprächen mit der ärzteschaft in den
krankenhäusern dass dort natürlich
ausreichend schutzkleidung da ist denn
das wichtigste ist ja dass die die im
gesundheitswesen auch tätig sind die
ärzte pflegekräfte und andere das auch
dort natürlich das infektionsrisiko
deutlich gen null wie bei allen aber da
insbesondere gen null reduziert wird
aber erstmal also waschen mit wasser und
seife gründliches waschen mit wasser und
seife ist völlig ausreichend um das
virus abzutöten und von den händen
abzuspülen natürlich ist es legitim wenn
man unterwegs auf reisen ist wo man
nicht immer ein wasserhahn und zweifel
zur verfügung hat dass man eine kleine
flasche mit desinfektionsmittel
vielleicht mit sich führt aber wie schon
gesagt haben wichtig ist es dass im
gesundheitswesen die alkoholisches
händedesinfektionsmittel vorhanden sind
in jedem krankenhaus und jede arztpraxis
weil da muss es wirklich schnell gehen
und auch da hat man nicht überall ein
waschbecken zur verfügung ist einfach
eine frage der solidarität dass die
mitbürger die gar kein
desinfektionsmittel brauchen darauf
verzichten zugunsten des
gesundheitswesens in meinen augen was
die maske betrifft mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen brauchen eine maske um
sich zu schützen im kontakt zu den
patienten aber es macht keinen sinn dass
wir alle hier mit masken rumlaufen das
hilft nicht das hat sich ja auch in
japan oder in china wo das
weit verbreitet ist gezeigt dass das
nicht der richtige weg ist
nächste frage neben das mikrofon vor ihm
danke frage ist es oft zu lesen
deshalb gesichert werden da vielleicht
einfach mal darauf hinweisen dass ist in
den letzten jahren keine sparmaßnahmen
also es gab kein spargesetz im
gesundheitswesen seit 24 jahren aber
schon seit vielen jahren nicht
mindestens zwei legislaturperioden jetzt
nicht also ein
die ausgaben steigen in allen bereichen
weil wir eben sagen in einer
wirtschaftlichen lage wie sie ist wollen
wir die gute wirtschaftliche lage ja
auch nutzen um in bessere versorgung zu
investieren das ist ja genau das was wir
in der vergangenheit gemacht haben dass
davon unbenommen die frage ist in der
pflege zum beispiel haben wir ja ich
meine das diskutieren wir seit zwei
jahren dass wir dort eben an bestimmten
stellen zu wenig personal haben und dort
ja jetzt auch nach steuern im moment ist
auch gar nicht geld das hauptthema
sondern der leer gefegte arbeitsmarkt
also die finanzen für zusätzliche
pflegekräfte sind seit spätestens anfang
letzten jahres ja da die stellen sind
finanziert der arbeitsmarkt ist wie er
ist gleichwohl will ich auch eins
einfach nochmal zur einordnung sagen es
dürfte weniger lenton wenige länder auf
der welt geben wo die relation zahl der
ärzte und zahl der pflegekräfte in
relation zur bevölkerung so gut ist wie
in deutschland ich weiß dass nicht alle
sozusagen akut in der versorgung
vollzeit zur verfügung stehen und stehen
können
aber wenn die wirklich in eine in einer
entwicklung hinein kämen wo wir auf
größerer front zusätzlich ärzte und
pflegekräfte bräuchten die sozusagen mit
anpacken dann bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher dass in einer solchen situation
so wie ich ärzte und pflegekräfte in
deutschland
sie jetzt nicht sagen ich habe aber hier
nur wie sie auch jetzt schon häufig
überstunden machen wenn es denn dann mal
wirklich eben auch knapp wird vor ort
das dann fiele ihm sagen dann packen wir
auch mit an in heinsberg ist dass gerade
der fallen da ist halt eine besondere
situation
und dann packen wir viele auch jenseits
sozusagen des regulären betriebes mit an
und das lässt mich eben dann doch ein
stück auch optimistisch sein und daher
auch meine aussage die er immer wieder
in der frage wie sehr sind wir
vorbereitet aufgegriffen wird also
gesundheitssystem insgesamt in der frage
wieviel fachkräfte fachpersonal
ärztinnen und ärzte wir in deutschland
haben im vergleich zu anderen
gesundheitssystemen auf der welt wenn
ich weiterhin der überzeugung dass auch
angesichts dessen was das virus stand
heute nach unserem wissen mit sich
bringt dass wir damit umgehen können das
heißt nicht das ist nicht im alltag ich
saß noch einmal zur einschränkung oder
auch besondere belastungen kommen kann
ja sie noch einmal land kreis heinsberg
akut und aktuell ja aber grundsätzlich
denke ich eher werden wir damit umgehen
können ich habe jetzt noch zehn fragen
ich schlage vor dass wir 15 minuten noch
machen und dann zum ende kommen
bitteschön problemen
die boni werden die geldscheine zeitung
waikato kann der regen auch exzellente
stelle ich wollte fragen ob es eine
tendenz aber schön wie viel genommen
worden weil dieses datum wurde bis
weiter gesagt das kann richtig die hre
zu sehen was hier in deutschland wenig
reden ein wenig testen müssen diesmal
zahl und ein fahrer her schon die einige
fluggesellschaften haben schon gestern
nicht über einen gestellten denken war
das wäre aber schließen sie das
aussterben dieser zeit machen oder das
kontrollen auf den zielkontrollen von
einem gipfel werden und dass es so kalt
stellen
ganz kurz also diese zahl kann ich ihnen
nicht nennen die zahlen gibt's wir
müssen die abfragen es gibt bestimmten
bereich von laboratorien gibt es wenige
große laboratorien die müssen uns die
zahlen freiwillig liefern wir sammeln
die es gibt zahlen aber ich kann ihnen
nicht genau sagen wann sie kommen aber
diese woche kommen alle zahlen die wir
haben sich auf die website
übrigens einer der notizen die ich mit
dieser tage mache ist dass wir in
solchen lagen schneller verpflichtend
wissen können müssen wie viele tests
insgesamt durchgeführt werden weil die
negativ test zahl mindestens so wichtig
ist zur einschätzung der gesamtlage wie
die positiv-test zahl müssen natürlich
im zweifel ich weiß nicht wie schnell
hofmeister wie viel abgerechnet wird
dann wie wenden es wird weniger länder
geben die schon so viele labore auch
haben auch in sozusagen im regulären
regulär betrieb der kassenärztlichen
versorgung wohl schon getestet werden
kann wie deutschland aber wissen halt
leider nicht
das fing er an mit testungen erstmal nur
an der charité daten war nur eine
uniklinik dann waren es 23 uni klinik
mittlerweile geht es relativ
flächendeckend wissen nicht genau wie
viel die frage ob flüge eingestellt
werden von fluggesellschaften ist die
entscheidung der fluggesellschaft die
frage die frage ist selber worauf
kontrolliert die debatte zu fieber
messen geht ja schon etwas länger ist
bleibt weiterhin meine überzeugung dass
bei einem krankheitsverlauf und einem
symptom verlauf wie er bei dieser
erkrankung ist fieber messen nicht
wirklich einen unterschied macht weil
eben viele derjenigen um die es geht
überhaupt keine symptome zeigen und oder
kein fieber zeigen und wir würden große
ressourcen an den flughäfen herr
gottschalk frankfurt sind sie maßgeblich
allein zuständig für die frage wir
würden ressourcen binden die wir an
anderer stelle im zweifel gerade besser
brauchen können was wir haben seit
samstag ist dass wir auch dort wollen
dass die fluggesellschaften die
sitzlehne vorrätig halten falls es eben
nachvollzogen werden muss wir halten den
gesetzen dass wir diese aussteige karten
haben
informationen haben dass wir das
ausgeben von flyern und
verhaltenshinweise verpflichtend auch
für bus und zug verkehr aus norditalien
eingeführt haben um insbesondere auch
dort weder diejenigen er zu informieren
die auf sich selbst achten dass das ist
ja erst mal ein gutes zeichen dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger wie etwa aus
norditalien so ist es ja auch in baden
württemberg der erste fall eben hat sich
ergeben dass jemand dann frühzeitig
gesagt hat ich glaube ich bin in einer
solchen situation ich hab symptom ich
komme aus norditalien und ich melde mich
dass wir also vor allem
verhaltenshinweise geben und informieren
aber eben nicht den ganzen verkehr
einstellen weil ich sage noch einmal das
einstellen von verkehren hat auch für
die versorgung folge zum einen als
praktiker auch ganz klar diese testung
von wir wissen inzwischen ja es gibt
völlig symptomfrei ansteckende menschen
dann ist das nutzer euro sicherheit und
auch das ein grund warum wir empfehlen
mit leichten erkältungssymptomen eben
auch nicht den praxen oder krankenhäuser
zu gehen um sich einfach testen zu
lassen
der zweite reserve hat völlig recht die
labors die sich im moment ausweiten die
die tests machen können die zahlen
laufen eben zurück bis zur abrechnung
können wir nicht warten das wäre zu lang
aber wir fragen die zurzeit ab so dass
wir noch in dieser woche das sehen wir
auch so zahlen bekommt wie viele tests
überhaupt bisher gemacht worden sind und
das wird der schnellste weg auch sein
natur
bisher steht zur haltung des körpers ins
central starten
das gerät ist dass ich dabei
ich würde sagen es hat natürlich es gibt
für beide ist argumente dafür und
dagegen wie bei so vielen dingen was ich
sagen muss und das will ich ausdrücklich
sagen dass meine ich auch so dass das
miteinander grad in dieser frage und in
dieser lage mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen in den bundesländern mit allen
16 ein sehr sehr gutes und konstruktives
ist da gibt es auch keinen streit über
zuständigkeiten oder sonstwas sondern
wir sind echt in einem regen austausch
nicht nur als minister sondern auch
unsere ministerien manchmal drei vier
fünf sechs mal die woche in
entsprechenden schalten auch mit dem
robert-koch-institut um sich fachlich
auszutauschen und sich über
vorgehensweisen auszutauschen also dass
das funktioniert sehr gut miteinander
und auch die verantwortungs beschreibung
auch dass es an bestimmten stellen
situationen gibt wo eine vielleicht
zusätzliche kompetenz etwa bei zentralen
unterbringung von rückkehrern sinn
machen kann ist unbenommen aber das sind
alles debatten müssen sie die würde ich
mir aufheben für wenn wir durch sind
weil das macht glaube ich mehr sind dann
auch politisch diese diskussion zu
führen
jetzt muss ich erst mal sagen klappt das
im miteinander wollten auch noch mit dem
landrat in heinsberg telefoniert wie man
das ja auch jenseits allerdings wäre
dann wenn es drauf ankommt wenn dann
eben irgendwo fragen oder unsicherheiten
sind weil es mir einfach wichtig ist
dass wir das dass wir als föderales
miteinander jetzt eben auch zeigen was
war was wir gemeinsam dann auch in so
einer lage schaffen können und ich finde
das klappt gerade in dieser lage sehr
sehr gut erfüllt wie wir dieses ja
[Musik]
es ist ohne zweifel eine 1 ein risiko
dafür da ja das haben wir auch schon
sehr früh adressiert das haben wir auch
seitens deutschland wie einige andere
länder auch im eu-gesundheitsminister
rat vor
jetzt geht es schon in zehn tagen zwölf
tagen vor vorletzte woche angesprochen
und thematisiert dass wir auch als
europäische union uns gemeinsam mit
beschäftigen müssen wissen sie mal ich
komme immer mehr zu der überzeugung dass
wir auch in folge dieser lage noch
einmal über das richtige maß an
globalisierung werden reden müssen ich
bin sehr für ökonomische arbeitsteilung
auf der welt und effiziente
arbeitsteilung auf der welt aber an
bestimmten stellen geht sicherheit vor
effizienz und die frage ob wir
produktionskapazitäten bei bestimmten
wirkstoffen bei bestimmten
sicherheitsprodukten stellen wir in
anderen bereichen ja auch die frage was
sollte in deutschland auf jeden fall
bleiben und in europa und sollte nicht
in andere länder oder hände kommen
das werden wir aus meiner sicht
unabhängig von dieser aktuellen lage die
situation war ja vorher schon eine wenn
wir noch mal miteinander diskutieren
müssen
frau emrich
ich sage noch einmal für die situation
die wir jetzt haben und so wie ich das
bestand heute auch sehen den letzten
wochen im miteinander im austausch
miteinander mit den behörden vor ort
sowohl ja auch bei der zentralen
rückkehr intensiven kontakt gehabt
herr gottschalk und die frage wie man
das am besten lösen
klappt das klappt das gut sehr gut in
war klar ich meine in lagen wir diesen
ist auch die frage feuer gesehen
das sind viele institutionen beteiligt
ist ja nicht nur föderales miteinander
wir haben das miteinander ja auch der
selbstverwaltung in der ärzteschaft ich
krieg da manchmal die frage gestellt
warum ich die ärzte nicht öfter direkt
informiere ich hab gleich kontakt zugang
direkt zu jeder arztpraxis sondern das
ist eben in unserem miteinander wie wir
es in deutschland haben dann über die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung die
ärztekammer sind viele institutionen das
ist eine stärke das aber so eine
institution miteinander sich eben in so
einer lage umstellt dass das erfordert
dann eben auch manchmal anstrengungen
und die mein eindruck ist das will ich
auch sagen seit wir seit letzten
mittwoch die neue lage in deutschland
haben nämlich eben nicht 16 infizierte
alles nachvollziehbar sondern das
infektionsgeschehen insbesondere im land
kreis heinsberg wo wir bis heute nicht
wissen wer ist der erste infizierte
gewesen woher kam der kontakt und diese
vielen kontakte die es gibt seit dieser
neuen lage ist meine mein eindruck dass
insgesamt alle institutionen und
beteiligten auch noch mal ganz anders
natürlich sich auf diese neue lage
eingestellt haben sodass wir sind
zusammen in eine neue phase getreten in
dieser in dieser entwicklung mit diesem
virus und ich muss sagen auch aus den
spitzengesprächen mit allen verbänden
ärzteschaft apothekern krankenhäusern
das system hat auch seine stärken wenn
ich alles zentral von einem entschieden
wird wenn wir gut miteinander
kooperieren und mein eindruck ist das
tun wir und das es unbenommen 1 der
situationen gibt wo möglicherweise auch
eine zusätzliche bundeskompetenz sinn
macht die debatte führen war dann
anschließend ich finde wir sollten das
gute miteinander
aktuell nicht damit belasten also man
kann da sehr viel sich auf einem blatt
papier zusammen rechnen
aber die realität ist dann doch ein
bisschen komplizierter also was ich
ihnen sage sind so kern schätzwerte um
die herum sich die realität aber dann
wieder ganz anders einstellt weil es
einfach bestimmte dinge gibt an die man
nicht denken zb virus kann sich nicht
frei verbreiten in der bevölkerung wir
haben kontakt netzwerke die stehen nicht
immer zur verfügung und die sind ein
paar monate später wieder durchmischt
und dann sind wieder neue
kontaktnetzwerke da das ist der grund
warum so etwas viel länger dauert bis es
sich verbreitet als man sich das so auf
dem blatt papier ausrechnen würde und es
gibt viele dinge viele eigentlich
selbstverständlichkeiten die man
vergisst wenn man da so anfängt sich
zahlen hin zu kritzeln zum beispiel
menschen sterben sowieso in deutschland
und zwar jedes jahr ungefähr 850000 und
diese zahlen muss man bei allen
überlegungen immer mit auf dieses blatt
papier schreiben und diese 850.000
menschen sie haben ein sehr ähnliches
alters profil wie auch die patienten die
an dieser virus erkrankung sterben und
auch da ist es so dass natürlich
patienten mit grunderkrankungen vor
allem sterben ältere patienten
und das ist auch bei diesem virus so und
sie können sich so vielleicht schon ein
bisschen vorstellen ohne auch zu rechnen
ab einem gewissen wert geht so eine
erkrankung auch ganz schnell im normalen
geschehen unter dann ist hier rinke dran
[Musik]
die frage ja das ist ja das thema das
wir in der europäischen union auch
miteinander haben ob nicht in bestimmten
bereichen auch wirkstoffproduktion
zurück nach europa kehren sollte
zumindest in sozusagen auch in der in
der vielfalt der lieferketten werden
moment die situation dass für manche
vorprodukte wirkstoffe ist nur einen
einzigen hersteller gibt nicht in europa
der dann zehn oder zwanzig
pharmazeutische unternehmer in
deutschland meinen für das gleiche blut
senkung medikament beliefert und wenn
der eine ausfällt sind alle 20 nicht
mehr lieferfähig in der folge und da
braucht es eine größere vielfalt erster
teil
und aus meiner sicht an bestimmten
stellen dafür muss aber europarechtliche
dinge ändern wenn beim vergaberecht an
bestimmten stellen möglicherweise auch
wieder produktionskapazitäten das gilt
nicht nur bei medikamenten auch in
europa und ich finde generell auch das
würde ich mal hinzufügen als gedanken
der mir jedenfalls die letzten tage
kommt auch mit blick auf das was in der
wirtschaft passiert dass das vielleicht
auch jetzt noch mal ein zeitpunkt ist wo
wir die starke abhängigkeit deutschlands
von einem großen markt vielleicht noch
mal miteinander auch in der perspektive
diskutieren sollten das ist kein akutes
thema aber die frage wie wir
wirtschaftspolitisch und so ausrichten
dass wir nicht so stark abhängig sind
vom china ökonomisch macht aus meiner
sicht sinn und ich finde die aktuelle
lage zeigt dass wir müssen leider zum
schluss kommen bitte sie mit der letzten
frage
wo ist eigentlich keinen sinn sie sich
präsentieren die bundesregierung auch
mit derzeit geschätzten jemals erreicht
ist der größte teil kräftigen draußen
ist oder zumindest eine politisch und
sämtliche stimmungen zu hören aber zum
ersten dass corinna virus ist ja in
deutschland und europa insofern sind wir
nicht mehr in der phase worum es da wo
es darum geht sozusagen zu verhindern
dass es nach deutschland und europa
kommt
insofern finde ich stellen sich die
fragen eben auch in der frage grenz also
thema grenze und migration
viele mir jetzt auch aktuell viele ein
aber ich will das jetzt bei einer
pressekonferenz die wir auch dass
corinna wir uns konzentrieren und die
folgen jetzt nicht hier machen aber was
des corona virus angeht müssen wir
einander feststellen es ist in
deutschland und europa und damit müssen
wir damit vor allem umgehen
die erste frage war wir gehen also erst
mal mache ich meine arbeit in den
letzten wochen so dass ich mich auch mit
vielen die jetzt hier sind und darüber
hinaus natürlich zuvörderst mit dem
robert-koch-institut austausche ich habe
ja schon beschrieben etwa in der frage
wo sitzt diese erkrankung lunge in der
lunge und anderes mehr haben wir auch
gemeinsam prozess sozusagen durch in der
diskussion und deswegen nämlich einfach
zahlen auf wie sie herr professor posten
sagt natürlich sehr sehr sehr sehr ernst
und mit den überlegungen hinein
das heißt aber nicht gleich dass ich
mich jeder zahl weil sie ja dann gleich
weiß wie die hätten hat die überschrift
dann auch wieder ich weiß doch was jetzt
als nächstes passiert je nachdem was ich
sage und ich habe nicht den eindruck
dass die überschrift die man im übrigen
auch schon aus der aussage von herrn
professor osten gemacht hat dass die
erstens die dinge richtig einordnet und
zweitens zudem beiträgt worum es
eigentlich geht nämlich zu sachlich zu
informieren und einzuordnen
das über einen langen verlauf ich weiß
da ich glaube sogar die schweinegrippe
ist heute noch in deutschland unterwegs
die hatte vor zehn jahren sozusagen ein
ausgangspunkt gehabt sie ist aber noch
da hat das über einen langen verlauf das
kann ich sagen kann in zwei jahren ist
das nicht mehr das ist anders händelbar
wir werden möglicherweise impfstoff
haben hoffentlich wir stecken ja auch
bundesregierung seit ich viel in
internationale kooperation zur
impfstoffentwicklung wir werden sicher
weise therapieoptionen haben das aber im
verlauf natürlich dann auch größere
teile der bevölkerung erkranken können
das ist so die frage ist wie schnell und
das ist genau das thema zu dem wir immer
wieder zurückkommen und das ist auch der
grund warum die maßnahmen zur eindämmung
ergreifen ich weiß nicht ob sie was
sagen kannst du der freiheit das bei
wärmerem wetter sich die dinge
vielleicht auch schon wenn wir jetzt mal
wenn es uns gelingt dass die grippewelle
abnimmt und damit das gesundheitswesen
weniger belastet wenn wir die vier
wochen gewinnen wer macht schon ein
riesen unterschied für die frage was
bedeutet das fürs gesundheitswesen
wenn wir schaffen das über zwölf monate
zu verlangsamen ist möglicherweise ein
impfstoff da ist macht dass ein
riesenunterschied für die frage was
bedeutet das für die bevölkerung und das
gesundheitswesen
und deswegen gibt es jetzt vor allem
verlangsamen und eindämmen aber zur
wahrheit gehört ihm auch dass das es
schon mehr als die deutlich mehr als die
150 aktuell gemeldeten infektionszahlen
in der perspektive werden die frage ist
wie schnell weil das hat folgen für die
frage wie gut wären wir damit fertig ich
habe den eindruck dass wir uns
angesichts dieser dynamik mindestens im
wochentakt ihr wiedersehen sollten
zumindest dann vielleicht in kleinerer
besetzung für heute vielen dank
dankeschön